[Music]
Hey
we're here yeah
welcome to the basement ladies and
gentlemen the cool the basement if you
haven't - didn't before this is
basically where the internet stores its
deepest darkest secrets and we're here
to let you in on them we don't want to
look at the outside of the car we're
looking to get under the hood slide on
one of those dollies I don't even know
what they're called underneath the car I
think they're called crawl no I don't
know does anybody know in the crowd okay
we have zero people with mechanical
capabilities we're off to a good start
here you guys ready for the first first
video here show moves on you guys are
gonna catch on in the morning all right
let's think so this first one everybody
knows that bullying is a huge problem
right okay so we found a anti-bullying
PSA and we want to take a look at it and
see if it's uh if it's an effective way
to treat bullies Johnny Lawrence his
ears aren't even laughs big bully
humiliated and scared by someone bigger
stronger or older than you
I've got fear of wars on the basketball
court but the let's pause it for a
second ah this guy's seen his share of
wars from the basketball field cream
dude Jabbar if you didn't know played a
lot in Vietnam there are I heard his NBA
Finals were referred to as the Korean
War yeah he got shot several times wait
on the court he played through it he did
play three to put a knee pad it was the
eighties Kareem I apologize I didn't
know that [ __ ] basketball was war
time does this kid know Creole Jabbar
Lee who just called them up on this
looks a little older they get a cell
phone
maybe like the payphone in the school is
a great they cream could you do a PSA
for me real quick about these [ __ ]
bullies oh goodness here that is a good
point those ears aren't big at all
they're fine also he's good he's gonna
grow into his ears like say I were the
bully which I never would be but I'd
make fun of that shirt over the years if
you're gonna be a bully though you would
have to dye your hair blonde blondes
always the bullies if blondes have more
fun and they bully more those sleeves
are way too long for a short sleep
that's like his dad's shirt and also the
other thing is when he said have you
ever been bullied by somebody bigger and
stronger than you what if you're getting
bullied by someone half your size
yeah like Joe Pesci every role he plays
he's like a badass guy Goodfellas is all
about Pesci being the biggest bully on
the block but he's 5 - so I guess we're
we're saying is they may be losing some
people is like hey my bullies 5-1 yeah I
they I'm being bullied by like a 8 year
old girl yeah I'm a 30 year old man all
right let's get back let's hear what
career back get back to creams talk
maybe if this guy didn't dress like an
idiot he wouldn't get bullied Oh bigger
stronger or older than you I've seen my
share of wars on the basketball court
but the last place you want to be at war
is all they make fun of cream that's why
it's important for you all of us to
become street smart that street cred
fully smart for kids for adults I guess
is that kind of a misleading title likes
really smarter so you don't get caught
avoid clothing that might make you look
like you're part of the game gag is that
guy associated with they do need a bully
smarter I feel like look at this [ __ ]
yeah bang what the guys weren't ready
even the Bloods would be like no way
what
I don't think gap has a gang like it's
this guy remember the Abercrombie look
at him come up here with his attitude
yeah there's no way that that guy's
gonna be misconstrued as a gang member I
could wear a shirt that says I'm in a
gang what is he part of the CPAs what
are you supposed to wear if you can't
wear that maybe this is a bully smarter
like this guy isn't part of a gang yeah
yeah we'll take this [ __ ] guy areas
where bullies are known to hang out
Tony's gonna be our bully we pause it
for a second well that's a kick was
crazy but what if lucky avoided it with
his hands behind his back and og Joe did
you see they showed that the dirty
alleyway they're like avoid places where
bullies figure out how many times and
bullies like hey meet me at that dirty
alleyway like every town is makeout
point there's also bullies alley okay so
you're like avoid that place and what
since when do gangbangers we're just
like oversized shirts like those kids
hanging out by the edge of the school I
think that's kind of a thing
those kids didn't look like gang members
to me at all they were they're bullies
they're not saying they're gay well I
don't know the one guy said don't wear
clothing to me that you associated with
a gang you're saying they're failing
that test I'm saying that this is
alright let's just continue on because I
think there's martial arts display oh
[ __ ] someone your shirt oh good
someone's shirt oh I didn't fall for it
he's got the hand oh I get what's going
on what do you want we watch anime you
always see a guy go like this and it
stop somebody in their tracks and just
go through the red light Anderson
Silva's main move was to grab someone by
the shoulders and shake him Hey look at
your shirt you would also say look at
that locate it looks like when he said
look at your shirt he was gonna grab her
boots he's like yeah I think he was like
after playing it wanted to and they're
like he probably did it once and they're
like dude what are you doing here I
think it's an odd they're an off-screen
couple he feels so comfortable with her
he almost forgot that they weren't in
their bedroom doing like the stuff
they're into what's the deal with the
punches these those you've never bullied
somebody like that yeah we like do it
like a speed bag other way he's just
quick noggin knocker
that's how confident he is that he can
just mess with you he's just gonna go
like this he's not going for knockouts
okay he's going for points so all right
put your hand up and basically it
renders all attacks useless why this guy
dressed like he's on the set of Pawn
Stars with polo that's a good point
let's get back into it you want to know
what they did half that's what he said
he goes I just wonder what they did in
math class well that was a good that
it's a good social thing to be anyone
who comes at you what do you want no
like oh I just wanted to know the
homework for English I've been sick
let's go Jessie Spano from Saved by the
Bell
and the works again after shows we will
teach you some stun techniques and dirty
tricks pretty good be careful not to
grab the hair loosely it will make the
hair pull less effective
what's the guys wearing a toupee high
school oh my god so just do that and
just run each make up the bully can't
run they are you don't want to teach you
how to punch
instead we first pause it for one second
so if you pull a guy's hair [ __ ] his
head to the left and then run quickly
he's totally defensive yeah you broke
through that was a neck break
oh she snapped it guys that is then how
do they even know what this guy wanted
we want to know what happened in math
but they they're like [ __ ] math we're
gonna break your neck and then we're
gonna run away what about the guys that
came up outside what if they wanted to
give him a check for $100 and he's like
whoa
is a [ __ ] stop what if it's a new Ed
McMahon he's like it's a million dollars
it's the kids version of Ed McMahon make
sure you don't grab the hair loosely
alright let's play instead we feel a
slap is more effective that's always
better than a punch wait that's what
it's an elbow
another effective slap it's to the
bully's groin oh how come his didn't
make any sound when he slapped his
crotch
cuz he wasn't hard Wow Oh a charley
horse knee once you've stomped on the
police foot run away and we guarantee
that he will be slow to follow
wait pause it for a second is this like
a money-back guarantee like if he kicks
your ass do you get kicked the [ __ ] out
of them
I don't know I'm just focused on her mom
jeans and they're distracting me it's
she's gonna trip she runs away and those
thing how can you guarantee that a bully
is not gonna chase after you when you
just literally stopped his foot lightly
they're wearing street smart polos you
know they know what they're talking
about
alright I'm gonna I'll take their word
for it let's uh let's continue on
fighting is another simple take fighting
oof oh she bit his titty that man has
AIDS
she just got HIV oh no oh now he's got
the upper hand sure this guy's trained
don't roll over on your stomach because
the bully will grab your hand with what
Pride Fighting throw the candy in his
face oh okay gives me enough time to run
all I have to do so the water right in
his face if a bullet applause for a
second here who's carrying candy
open-handed as they walk down the street
he's kids hang out with a lot of elderly
people so they always have hard candies
on them to throw did they think that
maybe they're being bullied because
they're carrying candy and the bullies
are like oh I want some of that do you
think the smell is a trash and the boys
you smell that Jolly Ranchers somebody's
carrying him open palms like I said Jude
you being somebody [ __ ] that guy up and
get him I smell Milk Duds I think it's
offensive that you know say a fat kids
bullying you and you throw candy in his
face and he's diabetic
yeah that's a really rubbing the salt in
the wound that's true and what is this
candy doused in mace how is candy in the
face gonna be like I'm blind I can't see
anything what if they eat the candy
then kick your ass catch it all in their
mouth I think it's dangerous this may
have been filmed around Halloween you
have a surplus of candy I've got to be
honest never walked down the street with
it just a palm full of candy ready to
throw but maybe I should I carry a
frozen baby Ruth yeah I don't like
weapons I think there's like a club
I carry a frozen chocolate covered
banana he's deep throating it as I walk
down the street I may attract a
different kind of different kind of boy
yeah I think this is a little bit old
school so we we've gone ahead and found
a newer school yeah PSA we've kind of
updated it for the 21st century let's
take a look at being bullied is it fun
so here are a few tips you can use to
keep those pesky bullies for making you
their next victim you may not know this
but your voice is actually a weapon ah
come on guys just leave me alone I have
to go home and bake cookies with mother
if politely asking them to stop doesn't
work fear not because you can use your
voice to call for help okay now you're
in a real pickle nobody's gonna help you
but face but don't worry slowly reach
behind you and pull out a homemade knife
or shank
[Music]
pick the Maine boy this is usually the
one that does most of the talking
stabbed him several times in the abdomen
and then the chest
[Music]
once the bullies on the ground do
something to convince the others that
you mean business
[Music]
Wow
you're not done yet remove the shank
from the body and leave the scene
dispose of the weapon with no murder
weapon it can be very challenging for a
prosecutor to get a conviction not so
fast
his family may vow revenge so take the
fight to them before they come to you
[Music]
good job but it doesn't end here you're
gonna need to move to a country that
doesn't have extradition Moldova is
beautiful this time of year go there and
create a new life for yourself don't
give another thoughts of those mean old
bullies are trying to ruin your day and
it's just that easy and now you know how
to get bullies off your back tune in
next week when we teach you how to get
your pimp to stop slapping you wow that
was amazing right thank you thank you I
think our way is way more effective I
agree with you and they think of
effective ways to battle we got these
people out here kicking some ass in San
Diego yeah we're gonna keep the theme
alive yeah people fight lights hi my
name is Jennifer Clark I'm with the
lightsaber team we're here in Balboa
Park and we're starting our first
meeting of the San Diego lightsaber team
business first as we get started I have
some liability waivers here injury these
[ __ ] people what are you gonna do
i entice elbow I have lightsaber wrist I
can't I gotta sue you guys
I stepped in [ __ ] I rub my shoes show
me a new pair that's a good point you
made cuz say you're just trying to have
a romantic picnic with your girlfriend
in this park yeah and then you see these
nerds with broomsticks and tennis
rackets
wait what qualifies as a lightsaber
basically anything I mean it's not real
so yeah I guess foam noodles so these
people are saying like we were in the
Star Wars so much that we're gonna take
the fictional weapons yeah and use that
as some form of fighting and guys like
one guy is like I got so much titty
sweat my shirt that I can't get it clean
you guys hope we didn't use sugar but he
signed the waiver so now they're like
[ __ ] you you think idea but we're like
wait my lawyer needs to look over this
for a sign anything I'm sure a lot of
people brought their lawyer with them
like I'm not gonna sign my life away
yeah I'm sure a lawyer looked at it goes
yeah I don't want you as a client
anymore some people I think would think
this is stupid just
like it's Star Wars what but I took a
fishing class that was just based on
Jaws in a park yeah
you just throw in the line we were just
on a Winnebago we're in the park they
teach us you had a like spear sharks
these throw it into the grass I actually
think this is a bigger issue because I
think our parks are being abused by
these people like there's people in my
park they do stick fighting where they
basically put like couch pillows on
their arms and stuff and they beat each
other with sticks it sounds cool I think
it's totally inappropriate so we do want
to start bullying these people I think
that we should throw can interface or
maybe candy in the streets and they'll
run out and go get it judging by the
agendize I think the candy would the
feeding frenzy do you think that the
actual well I guess it's all mind power
but is there any to get in to be like a
real Jedi in Star Wars was there any
physical endurance it's like a
fraternity you got to do time you get
hazed by okay it'll be one like puts his
balls on your head while you're sleeping
there's a ton Isaac a lot of hazing okay
Skyler get such a shitty haircut they're
really putting them through them you
wake up with like Yoda's pubes been
shaved off your face by the way how low
is this guy in the totem pole is to
carry the equipment I thought that was a
woman that's a beauty oh that's a dude
okay and they're like hey man you got to
carry the sticks we made that are
supposed to be like that we wrapped two
phone
I don't agree if you're gonna do this I
think you should definitely do it in
your own backyard stop abusing public
lands and by the way to piggyback on the
bullying I think this guy to avoid
bullying should not have his strap go
through his tits it's just calling
attention to those big beautiful
briefers yeah yeah those are Jedi worthy
let's hit play and see these people take
a look there who does fitness and
choreography with lightsabers I
absolutely love what they do it's just a
little hard to drive to Inland Empire
for regular meetings so I thought kind
of let's have one here in San Diego I'm
sure there's other people who'd love to
come out and play with lightsabers
I get to have a lightsaber and play I am
an only child
why is she curling why is there being an
only child combination of like fake
fighting
like nametags well
so I'm meetup calm there was a
lightsaber group which is cool I love
sci-fi and I love Star Wars I've also
kind of like Theo von European martial
arts this guy the ring I realized that
you know what
Star Wars is one of these people walking
by hobby along got a Jedi ponytail or
cast I'm in my socialization time I
wanted to find my tribe I wanted to find
socialization like the things I like I
could understand my record you fight
slow-mo these guys are gonna [ __ ]
enjoy the things that I enjoy why does
another guy on the right have the longer
Sabres fan and I'm here personally to
get exercise the only way I'll get
exercise so she's saying the only way I
get exercise is by big a Jedi Knight I
mean this exercise is you could do it in
your living room you could just sweep
your house get better exercise than this
imagine going to the gym and you're just
like hold on guys did you take out
whatever their use they can do these
stupid routine and you're just hitting
people in the face well I'm trying to do
leg presses why is it all so slow and by
the way if you can wear jeans I don't
know if it's exercise look at that lady
in the back my dress for exercise yeah I
agree 100% that lady on the rights like
she thought this was an aerobics class
her boyfriend took her and she's like oh
boy I left the backdrop somebody was
probably playing an impromptu game a
soccer and they're like well you guys go
play by the wall I'd love to see a
homeless guy right between those two
trees to take a [ __ ] yeah or jerking it
that's like the lady in the tight
spandex like can you leave he's like hey
man I'm this is my jerk-off class I
could see if the camera panned right to
the right you just see him there they're
like dude can you stop please think I
love Jedi play let's play can we fast I
would also like to see one of these
people joking around just deepthroating
this lady
Billy Madison alright let's let's let's
go through our meetings consists of a
nice warm-up to get the muscles loosened
up and then we go into practicing forms
we have a couple of different styles we
tortoise you don't want to get splinters
on that broomstick had no choreography
so you're learning how to sort of see
ass also wearing
duel between two people they walked us
through the basic stance of using a
light since I really want to kill their
basic sweeping motions which are really
cool who sell the ground up so
determines valuation works best for you
this guy long stick and this is what you
use when you don't know what you're
doing and so far an only child who would
have taught you swing and I've learned
to switch it and then we swing to old
have purple hair better natural color
same exact craft
our goal is never to have full contact
fighting we understand sometimes those
things happen but it's never our goal
physics yeah that blonde guy probably
their saber to work out with out of [ __ ]
he's tight and the other comes be
equipment classics head around let's
definitely do it
he's rivals with the other ponytail so
we gonna be saying there can only be one
staff spear type weapon and basically
consists of only three parts the blade
itself the body and a little another
piece of metal to see makes people at
home yeah
securely stepping forward on curling
sweep to the leg his mom's like one of
my brew bring their bodies first of all
so that biggest mom I'm talking to you
not the [ __ ] Wade your private buttons
into the base the shaved guy just like
let me hit someone endurance
he just wanted this guy in television we
have about five different speeds when
they were burning in teaching people the
movements we go at one precision guy
look at he's been working moving very
slowly that other guy look like the you
know guy fast as you can 1% is our Tai
Chi speed
I mean really as hard as you can
whoa that guy got to kill Matty is the
guy the one hundred ten percent we want
you to go as fast as you possibly can I
feel like I'm getting a workout my
thighs the guy who left pauses for a
second we should wrap this one up and I
gotta laughs looks like a prison guard
during the day and he's getting so he'd
like wants to work his frustration out
on these [ __ ] these Jedi's yeah he
seems like he's a couple loose they do
any like background checks out like
whatever you're just an absolute psycho
you start nailing people in the throat
what if you just have a real samurai
sword that you cover in foam [ __ ]
chopping people it's a good idea for
when we join this no no it's cool we
need to start our the Danish Antonio
lightsaber team yeah we fight like we
put like diseases on our web better yeah
well we the Danish Antonio bullwhip team
oh we just go out there with the [ __ ]
out of people all right let's move on we
could watch these people the rest of our
lives but are we really gonna learn
anything no yeah well learn what not to
do with this next video though we are
gonna learn a lot I have a few I'm
excited what do we have here we have one
of the best martial artists in the world
okay let's they're gonna show us how to
fight properly
whoa oh this guy stop that watch out oh
posit what he goes to Supercuts and just
turns his head by accident and breaks
the guy's hand killed the woman cutting
his hair like his body is naturally
attuned to danger so when scissors come
near he just felt like his hair is
what's the way I think oh my fingers
have just been shattered is this a porno
set that they're like we're not using it
for the day let's give it to this
martial artist in his friend I think
this is also like a city park because
this isn't this guy's backyard and a
city park is like a koi pond and asian
thieves
I think there's agent themed koi pond
parks I want to hang out there trust me
we gonna run into this guy I like that
he's not wearing a matching top and
bottom karate well it looks like he's
wearing karate G pants but a polo shirt
hey thank you I think he was golfing and
he's like [ __ ] I only have the bottom I
think he golf's in karate keypad I would
hope and no Club he just uses his mind
to send the ball to the hole he's on the
PGA Tour actually guy on the right to
call back looks kind of like a short
Korea blue Jabbar oh he looks like
you've seen some Wars out on the
blacktop it's it's uh more than that koi
pond look at that guy with the
spread-eagle fall they're just smelling
it again I think you can see it looks
like is nutsack sweat dripping out of
those deep it's the second time I'm
noticing these things it's not my fault
it's the martial art I think yeah you
probably won't get this but I think it's
Bill Laimbeer from the Detroit Pistons
oh I don't bill that beer right there
how dare you say that Bill Laimbeer let
himself go like that he did Bill
Laimbeer was like seven feet tall who
and beer zappysys okay alright let's hit
play let's see what else this guy's got
in store
oh I fear for these people it's a limbo
at a bar mitzva whoa whoa
oh yeah that's typically why why are
they giggling never get the oh how is he
doing this with his mind
I like how calm he is posit he's like
look man you can't oversell it I'm
trying to make this look real you can't
be doing this screaming I've talked to
you about this I think that's why the
women aren't in these because they were
doing a lot of giggling yeah where do
you find these people who are like yeah
you guys want to do some fake martial
arts and a field fake yeah
what are you talking about I apologize
if I believe this may not be real I
thought you were gonna say where do you
find people that will willingly allow
them be themselves to be subjected to
this sort of torture are they signing
waivers this guy once you grab that pole
once you grab his ball he's gonna be
jerking around with it it seems like
when the women grabbed the pole he may
be doing bigger yeah it's it seemed to
be affecting them differently maybe he's
tickling the vagina with his mind whoa I
didn't even think it's gonna be a me-too
situation it could be this guy could be
mentally stimulating their clitorises
yeah yeah Wow he could be mentally
making everybody horny this guy
definitely has gold chains on doesn't he
I would hope I'm not one to talk yeah
but all right let's keep moving through
here by the way meticulous
well whoa what's he gonna do Oh doc put
my baby was asleep every night this lady
hates it in the top she won't fall down
she's giggling look at her I think
that's his wife he's like it's like I
don't want to do this anymore I just
fall down [ __ ] the grass stains who
cares yeah that is a bad thing with
these white gay pants grass stains yeah
look at that guy got choked and that guy
seems to get the worst of it every time
he hates that guy that guy [ __ ] his
wife one year you mean Tina at the
Christmas party they had sex you say
there's a Christmas party for this why
wouldn't it I would love to go there so
what does the guy do you've had enough
punch and they just [ __ ] knocks it
out of your hand without touching you
yeah
I'd hate to see that guy when he gets
drunk does he just depantsed you with
his mind I don't know she just punching
you in the face without I wish he was
here how's that car doing really cute
hook me up with your guy yeah two head
scare the [ __ ] out of ya that's [ __ ]
wild
sensei Larry's here what yeah he's
[ __ ] it but here he comes
hey guys oh hey man what's up dude hey
yeah
flies down what I wasn't talking to you
your fly's down
are you sure yeah cuz I can see your
tiny little dick poking the Terra ha ha
ha good one man that's good
why are you slapping yourself hey clean
out ah we're just trying to have a good
time
will you please pull your pants up god
damn it come on man trying to be cool
I'm just messing around look man I think
you probably had one too many we're not
in class we're not alone so why do you
want me to leave you alone I don't get
what that means
if everything was so cool why would I
have a piece of pizza on my hand like
this I don't know how to answer that
sensei it doesn't matter how you answer
it as long as you answer it why are you
choking yourself one man stop it dude
you're gonna hurt it come on man
dude stop just leave him alone
seriously look me win twenty trouble I
never touched him I didn't touch him I
know what you're doing how do you know
what I'm doing unless you're doing what
I'm doing I don't know you ever been
punched in the face with another man's
brain
look man you're hurting him just asking
a question no you're not I really what
you do we take class with you sensei
look I get it
this isn't safe let's just go look guys
I'm sorry
no hard feelings whose [ __ ] neck man
you're out of your goddamn mind
this part is lame oh I almost forgot
I didn't get any cake
evidently that's also an effective way
to treat bullies yeah
use your mind all right let's uh let's
get on to our last segment shall we now
in previous episode we did a story about
a man in New York who fought his whole
life to get the nunchuck ban taken away
we actually have a clip from a previous
episode we'll show you that now this is
uh this is the tale of a man named Steve
Maloney he was arrested in 2000 for
possession and nunchucks in the state of
New York
that's crazy a lot of people aren't
talking about this you cannot have you
can't have nunchucks in New York and the
reason is because of the martial arts
craze in the 70s like what ton of
martial arts movies came out and they
thought that the youth of the time would
see the weapons and decide to use them
to attack people on the streets yeah I
think if Bruce Lee did anything negative
that would be it because yeah they said
he was one of the big reasons all right
now that you're all up to speed
yeah let's dive into this - this
nunchuck update that we have I I let
them use this picture from my apartment
for this is that are you wearing a hood
or is that your hair that's not me
that's a guy I'm a fan of okay okay
those are nice nunchucks look he didn't
have any foam padding but you have a
string this guy's got metal in between
well you know how I feel I'm a purist I
like the strings it is it where do you
buy a sleeveless hood at the aedra Dice
Clay summer line I think you make that
yourself I think you cut that with
scissors okay I leave the hood don't
tell ya yeah he's pointing yeah so the
update is yeah the update is that
Arizona has overturned and New York has
overturned it so they're now legal yeah
in Arizona
yeah so what Arizona start carrying
those chucks ah look at this is that
cats in Arizona is like [ __ ] yeah
finally I could be a karate champion
I've tried to get my cat to learn
martial arts did not work out well yeah
for me because it learned too well and
now it's people [ __ ] out of me all the
time well that's not the one you killed
with a spin kick as I said you got to
block the kick yeah the second
oh yeah actually would love to use two
cattails tie them together and use the
cats as nunchuck didn't tell you that in
the bullying thing that a few abused
animals you might be oh what you should
do is carry a dog with you just throw it
at the bully like a German Shepherd yeah
that you don't feed just take a muzzle
off and then throw it at them but it
would attack your candy pocket
immediately throw what you do is you
throw raw meat on them blood robbing
that you throw a dog like a rabid dog on
it's a lot of preparation to treat these
bullies you're better off just letting
them beat the [ __ ] out of you I gotta be
honest with you for real its way less
prep this cat scaring the [ __ ] out of me
I think we overestimated amount of
material on this nunchuck cat yeah can
we pull a fast one and go back to the
bullying you want to go back all right
yeah let's take a look why not sometimes
you got to date your ex-girlfriend one
more time agree see what see what if the
magic is still there effective slap its
to the bully's groin
well that one made a sound how do you
expect the guy to come if you just slap
it oh well the old we kissed once you
stomped on the police you slap them in
the garden no angry he's gonna get what
you should do is slap it and then grab
it squeeze it
biting is another simple tank yeah and
then the bully won't be angry anymore if
a bully is approaching you you've got a
magazine just roll it up hit him and run
what are they a [ __ ] puppy so
basically you need to walk around with a
magazine in a cup of water like you just
slap that guy Wow
oh he's never gonna be able to get up
from that that's gonna ruin his hair for
life yeah they're like what's wrong with
your hair Oh 20 years ago this guy
grabbed it and threw me to the ground
who walks out of the house like they're
getting ready to take a [ __ ] they're
candy their bag is even a cup of water
pick up my cup of water I got my
magazines yeah el Pasto enchilada sauce
in case when some of the crowd bolt
charges me I throw it in their face so
every child needs to walk around like
he's like a 40s
old man it's why these kids have
scoliosis is they're carrying not only
their books but also stuff to combat the
world that's crazy
yeah and also do you who carries
magazines now everything's digital well
then you throw your laptop in their face
oh you're like hey take a look at this
magazine yeah
like you see this website and you break
it over their head you're like good
thing that was my fake laptop my real
laptops it might think we almost forgot
on this show we always have a comedic
guest do a little stand-up yeah and a
lot of these shows you see on the
late-night shows that the comic is
facing the audience yeah and the host
they actually don't get to enjoy the act
whatsoever so we're gonna do it a little
differently here on the basement we're
gonna have the comic face us so we can
enjoy it and so the audience won't enjoy
it at all ladies and gentlemen
introducing one of the best comics
international superstar get it for Fang
Chow guys I'll actually be doing all of
the recording for this if I could figure
out how to turn the camera on where's
the power button oh here we go
[Laughter]
that's good stuff
I went too far on out I don't think it
went far enough oh man keep going keep
going
[Music]